jochen und sigrid schaller die beiden
sind durch die absolute hölle gegangen
vor 27 jahren wurde ihre damals
16-jährige tochter nicole ermordet 25
jahre später nimmt die polizei ralf h
fest eine neue dna untersuchung zeigt er
gilt als dringend tatverdächtig 2008
2018 wird ihm der prozess gemacht doch
zum urteil kommt es nicht stattdessen
wird der prozess im märz beendet ralf h
kommt aus der u-haft und jetzt beginnt
alles von vorne
warum und wenig hölschers eltern das
verkraften weiß bild nach 27
verhandlungstagen wird der prozess gegen
rafa im märz beendet er kommt im juli
sogar wieder frei und das obwohl er
weiterhin als dringend tatverdächtig
gilt vor 27 jahren die 16 jährige nicole
scharrer ermordet zu haben
der grund für die freilassung von reiss
ist unter anderem die korona pandemie es
sei nicht mehr zumutbar ihn in u haft zu
lassen ein schock für die eltern von
nicole das ist ein schlag ins gesicht
wir haben so viele oder bereiten weitere
tochter gestorben ist
so geht das ja verstehen
heute wird der prozess vor dem
landgericht dortmund neu aufgerollt denn
in diesem verfahren ist so einiges
schief gelaufen akten zur
prozessvorbereitung gegen auf dem weg
zum angeklagten verloren
eine richterin war dauerhaft erkrankt
die konsequenz neuauflage des prozesses
das ist natürlich ein ganz besonderes
verfahren ich glaube dass uns die selten
so viel schief geht wie es in diesem
verfahren der fall ist es ist schon
recht turbulent chance das zu erklären
was ihr in den verfahren alles passiert
ist ist für mich nahezu unmöglich in
zwei wochen soll der prozess fortgesetzt
werden
die eltern von nicole scharrer hoffen
dass das verfahren schnell ein ende
findet eine gerechtigkeit in deutschland
angeklagt
für ganz ganz lange zeit ins gefängnis
kommt wirklich nützliche erfahrung
michael engelberg berichtet von anfang
an über den prozess michael wir haben
gerade die eltern im beitrag gesehen du
konntest mit ihnen sprechen
wie geht es den eltern jetzt wie
verkraften sie ist dass der mutmaßliche
mörder ihrer tochter auf freiem fuß ist
also wenn man in die augen der familie
schaller geguckt hat muss man sagen dass
sie natürlich
extrem traurig sind seit 27 jahren
warten sie auf eine antworten seit 27
jahren und warten sie darauf zu wissen
warum ihre tochter sterben musste
frau schaller hat mir heute nach dem
prozess gesagt sie sind einfach mit
ihren nerven am ende
sie sind seit 27 jahren in der trauer
jetzt ist der erste prozess geplatzt
heute hätten sie ihm theoretisch auf dem
gang begegnen können er hat wie familie
schaller das gericht durch den gleichen
eingang betreten also durch die tür des
des schwurgerichtssaals die familie ist
wirklich in tiefer trauer
und man muss sagen dass sie das jetzt
noch mal durchstehen müssen das ist
schon wirklich zu erhalten es ist
unvorstellbar und wir haben die bilder
gesehen von den mutmaßlichen täter der
heute eine smiley maske getragen hat
eine smiley maske mit einem smiley nach
unten haben die eltern darauf reagiert
immerhin ist das ja eine öffentliche
beleidigung möchte ich jetzt sagen ja
also natürlich können sich die eltern
jetzt jeden tag und jeden
verhandlungstag an ralf h abarbeiten man
muss aber natürlich auch sagen dass
alpha natürlich um für sein recht kämpft
er kämpft dafür nicht lebenslang ins
gefängnis zu gehen und nicht in
sicherungsverwahrung zu kommen aber
natürlich ist das für die eltern eine
absolute absolute vollkatastrophe seit
27 jahren wie gesagt warten sie auf den
entscheidenden moment für sie war es ja
fast schon abgehakt bis 2018 neue
verdächtigungen hochkamen mit einer
neuen dna analyse ist man auf ralf hage
kommen dann fängt der prozess an 27
verhandlungstage wird verhandelt man ist
immer kurz vorm ende kurz vor einer
verurteilung und dann platzt das ganze
in sich zusammen für die eltern ist das
ein alptraum und ist eine absolute
zumutung und ich muss ehrlich gesagt
sagen ich bin jetzt schon etwas länger
gerichtsreporter aber mit welcher ruhe
die familie das durchsteht und mit
welcher inneren zerrissenheit aber
trotzdem versuchen nach außen das
gesicht zu wahren
das ist schon wirklich wirklich sehr
sehr bemerkenswert und sie wollen dass
der prozess schnell zu ende geht
da glaube ich ehrlich gesagt nicht dran
heute sind schon erste formalitäten
wieder wieder angemerkt worden ralf hahn
möchte den richter ablehnen und hat
einen antrag durch sein verteidiger
gestellt und ich gehe davon aus dass
auch in zwei wochen
halfar kein wort sagen kann und nicht
wird es wird auch wieder in formalitäten
enden und ein ende des prozesses ist für
mich lange nicht
michael engelberg vielen sagen wir
wünschen natürlich trotzdem der familie
dass sie das alles einigermaßen gut
überstehen ich danke dir für den moment